il ya quelques années michel singelé
déneiger les entrées et stationnement
des résidences et entreprises dans le
jargon du métier il se chargeait de
déneigement privées à l'impôt vraiment
de règle respectée chance le nom est en
ligne et délits contre aussi vous faut
respecter les contrôles
respectez service
il doit maintenant respecter plus de
règles parce qu'ils effectuent les
opérations de déneigement pour la ville
de montréal
ce qu'on appelle des logements publics
au québec l'enlèvement de la neige et de
compétences municipales et provinciales
il règle encadrant l'entrepreneur qui
déneigent votre entrée par exemple varie
d'une municipalité à l'autre c'est du
public sont plus nombreuses car elles
doivent répondre aux exigences des
villes et celles du ministère des
transports au niveau du municipal
on a des devis des cahiers de charges
alors les cautionnements légale en titre
subissions la machinerie to dvd filles
et tout le monde est égal tandis que
dans le privé c'est des contrats donnés
de gré à gré l'association des
entrepreneurs de déneigement du québec
souhaite que les entreprises privées
répondent aux mêmes critères
elle rédige actuellement un projet de
règlement sur la question devant
comprendre une formation sur la
circulation à proximité des piétons les
problèmes de fatigue les techniques de
virages et les règles de secourisme
notamment le président de l'association
cite l'exemple de cette entreprise de
longueuil qui forment tous ses employés
chaque machine et son livret
d'information de shera questions de
sécurité puis on reçoit aussi de nos
employés pour la sécurité le nombre de
collisions impliquant des véhicules de
déneigement est en hausse au québec il
est passé de 490 en 2015 2016 à plus de
776 en 2007 2018
on n'est pas exempt de aucune accident
sauf que dans le milieu urbain on n'est
ce pas et puis on pense que les
handballeurs forme plus leur chauffeur
on voudrait aussi que ce soit la même
chose dans l'institutionnel le
commercial et résidentiel